Once cursed, a
witch's curse is known as an eternal bondage that cannot be broken until death due to the difficulty of the mysterious incident.There are
two ways to break it.One is the
kiss of love of the prince on a white horse.That is from the
heart of pure mutual love with a human being.
Two Kisses It's up to the whims of the meat witch, which means the only thing I can do is have the
person who placed the curse break the curse, but
unfortunately I'm not the witch you're looking for,
so I can't break the curse.I was mistaken for this witch.  I don't know
, but it was a wasted effort.
You also made one mistake. You
don't have to be the lord of the curse to break the witch's curse.
[Music]
A3
Kiss There are
n't just two ways to break the curse
[Music]
What